i'm never ever
marking anything in my life well i can't
say that i'm marking me
hey what's up gq
d rod here dennis rodman
and these are my essentials
[Music]
it's probably one of my favorite things
in the world besides my kids
and maybe a female species i think
everyone in the world knows i smoke
cigars
on top of my voice these are my favorite
cigarettes money crystals you know white
label they're almost gone you know
tonight they'll be gone but uh ah man i
messed with cigars ever since 94. i
can't seem to put it down it's like a
lifesaver sometimes to me because it
keeps me calm humble healthy wealthy and
wise as you can see i'm gonna smoke one
right now because you know i had one all
day
matter of fact you can go to north korea
and get them because he gave me seven
boxes one day and i brought them back
they were very delicious very moist
and very pure so go to north korea get
your cigars it's like a baby rattle you
know if you if you start crying like one
two years i mean one or two three months
you need that rather to keep you calm
keep you sane
so this is my rattle to me my money
crystal cigars
this song here black
who don't know that song black by this
guy and this band
pro jam who don't like this band on the
planet earth
maybe the devil i don't know
he's not playing on everybody he always
walks pearl jam i got hooked to these
guys in 1991
and um it was amazing i had a bit of an
issue in 1993. you know i want to uh
commit that hold that thing called
suicide it's amazing that look back at
this like wow
this brings like a lot of and this is
like a top two
a top two right here
this is funny and i'll turn my work to
black
tattoo everything
my word to black
see
that i am or how can i be yeah
i mean it's just it's so it's so true
you hear these lyrics
i mean you have these lyrics right here
it's so true and it's so like um
[Music]
wow it's more than chill bumps it smells
like damn it's like heavenly felt
it's like it's like you just float a
cloud 55
or 91
or 110 they saved my life man i try to
commit suicide and for some of the
reason the voice of love came in my life
at that particular moment that night
and it was pearl jam and i think pro jam
for doing that for me
not the sole reason but
it was the main reason
so i don't have piercings right here on
the table but you can see in my face
here nose ring lip ring this ring i used
to have here and always down here
but um
no matter if i can probably get them
this week i mean when i first
got my first piercing in my nose
it was like
almost like a life-changing experience
because
who would imagine a
a guy coming from the projects
in i don't know 1981
92 82 with have pierces you know in the
nba i think i'm the first guy to ever
have piercings in the nba they was
telling me back then i was dressing like
jim morrison jimmy hendrix
robert page
all these guys back there because if you
look at their styles in my style back
then we're like the same we looked the
same with the bell bottoms the hip
huggers the tight shirts what what
people said about me back then
it was always a good thing it was never
a negative thing because i never
disrespected anyone for dressing like a
community loved me because i you know i
love my gay parts i love my gay family
i'm just so happy the fact that i still
have some type of reputation that people
actually like me today i'm still doing
it i'm still i'm making products and
stuff like that around the world and uh
you know i hope it uh last um decades to
come
[Music]
this is just a future choice i made up
me and my my friends my partners this is
pretty cool i think you guys will like
this one so like i said
rotmanbrand.com guys check it out
you'll see everything
so here's another right here this is
pretty cool too what do you guys think
my god wow look how young that kid looks
that's the antique in itself
the barber head look at that look at
that look at that guys isn't that funny
but this is cool man doesn't matter 93
know that means
chicago 91 the lakers 73
that's why i did it that way so if you
look at the hair
different right
so that's just one just a sample
and you can get this at robinbrand.com
so
check it out
well i'll tell you one thing this is
like one of the probably the top three
lifesavers in my life
this exercise man
[Music]
it almost killed me the other day
because i got popping an eye with this
damn thing but uh i've been doing this
right here for
oh man let's see
over 20 years this comes in handy
because sometimes you don't want to go
to the gym at all i mean you don't want
to go there
and uh i just got into these things when
i hear a friend of mine said dennis you
should try these bands they're just like
wasted but the resistance and i just got
hooked real quick i mean real quick and
i'm like wow i can do this all day long
take this sometimes when i'm like
down and out sometimes and then go
outside and just start working out and
just you know it makes me feel good and
get a good pump and uh and actually you
feel good afterwards i'm trying to
comment on the nba today you know nba is
made for the 22nd century
um a lot of nba players they used to
play back in the 80s and 90s and early
2000s they think it's very soft it's
very weak to me i don't care my son's
gonna be in the nba next year so you
know who am i to judge
[Music]
some days when you have a rough day you
have to you know cover up some things
that you don't want people to see
so get something like this and try to
make up something that i i've screwed up
the night before partying too hard or
maybe just living a life of dream a
luxury when i was a kid my sister they
dressed me up in makeup dressed with
women's clothes and stuff like this so
in the 90s i just brought it all back
you know but it was my preference it
made me happy made me feel good made me
feel free this is like
a savior to a lot of people around the
world i mean men women actors
entertainers
athletes you know you name it this
foundation it saves a lot of people's
lives and guess what thank god i found
this guy years ago thank you foundation
what we have here i think everyone in
orange county knows it's called black
flies man out of orange county
california i've been wearing black flies
for a long time
and finally they made me a pair of
shades with my face on these are my
signature dennis robin eyewear
it's called dennis robin
the ball the reason why they're made so
big because of my face my face is kind
of long and stuff like that i made these
glasses for tall guys with big people so
you know have room to breed
most of the glass you see they're pretty
much tight over years but these right
here very comfortable and you can
actually see in them oh yeah i have
designed these about two and a half
years ago and they finally came in about
a year ago and uh and people always
trying to like can i wear those
obviously they're gonna steal them but
so it's okay guys yeah go ahead you see
the logo dennis rodman you see black
flies right there it's all good guys
it's called man the alpha use your own
imagination i love it man because you
know it's like an energy booster right
but it's more like it enhances for your
testosterone no side effects
no you know eye problems no liver
problems no heart problems lung problems
it's actually it's good for you mentally
and physically i need it because i'm 60
years old but uh i'm happy that this guy
brought me a board because i'm happy to
be a part of this just the group
mandy f up so hope you guys go out and
buy this man
[Music]
these braces right
i just started wearing braces man over
many many years but um
you know as time go on they seem to to
wear and tear because i had like 10 of
this armature on this arm in different
parts of the country and
when i was doing a reality show a couple
days ago
they all they all just disintegrated off
my wrist and i'm like oh my god i gotta
start over again right
so i was pretty pissed about that but i
like the most because most of these
things are i have a little symbol as far
as where i've been where i came from
but uh i can get them back i mean
the light goes on i'ma go on but these
things
they have sentimental values like a lot
of people in the world do they say
gold braces civil braces platinum braces
keep you sane keep your humble keep you
calm and normal i can't say i won't die
for him
no i won't do that
[Music]
i think a lot of people that play sports
you know you see a lot of guys you see
them in the locker room that's the first
thing they do when they come out to
shower or steam room sauna
they uh they don't get the lotion they
get the moisturizer to soak in their
skin especially when you're black your
skin gets so damn dry and stuff like
that so moisturizing it works very well
for the black skin my kids always say
why do you use these things why do you
use the moisturizer why do you do this
well i mean you know some days when you
get old your skin get a little dry so
you have to use this moisturizer man
very important to i mean keep your skin
on point
thank you guys for checking me out on my
10 essentials that i presented to you
today
hope you guys had a blast either way
it's time to go party enjoy your life
guys check it later